BRIAN KINDLER: Hi everybody.
Thank you for coming
to the second event
in our Burma Series.
My name is Brian Kindler.
I'm the creator of Burma Series,
along with Google
Ideas, who has generously
sponsored this event.
Today, we're lucky to have
with us Doctor Robert H.
Lieberman, a physicist from
Cornell University, whose 50
year career has included the
creation of six novels, and
almost as many films, the latest
of which, "They Call it
Myanmar," was screened the other
night here at Google.
Dr. Lieberman is going to be
speaking with us today about
contemporary Burma, and
answering questions.
Please join with me to welcome
Dr. Robert Lieberman.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: I'm going
to run this like I run
my physics class.
Basically, I'm going to start
assuming nothing, and so it's
better to find out where
students are and take them
along, as opposed to--
how many of you have seen the
film "They Call it Myanmar"?
So some haven't.
You can stream it now.
It's on all major digital
platforms, you know, Netflix,
iTunes, and we have a website,
theycallitmyanmar.com.
And anyhow, so Brian wanted me
to tell you about myself a
little bit, so let me
introduce myself.
I have a number of careers.
I teach physics at Cornell.
I've been on the faculty there
for about 30 years.
I've been writing novels for
even longer than that, and
short stories, and
I make movies.
And I make movies because
we're really in the
post-literate generation, so
I've done fiction films, I've
done a comedy called "Green
Lights," and I've done a film
in Ethiopia during the
famine, various films
Anyhow, I'd like to talk to you
about Burma today, and I
have some notes, but I probably,
knowing myself,
won't use them.
You know, I would like to look
at Burma as a Martian would
look at it, or better yet, I'd
like to use Google Earth and
sort of zoom in on Burma.
And if you do that, and you're
sort of looking at Southeast
Asia, if you look at the
countries surrounding Burma,
it's kind of interesting,
because none of them really
are a beacon of democracy.
There's Vietnam.
If you talk out against the
government, you're in trouble.
Laos is a communist country.
I just got back from Cambodia.
Hun Sen, who's the Prime
Minister, was put in place by
the Vietnamese after the
Pol Pot slaughter
of 3 million people.
Thailand, although it's
nominally a democracy, say
something bad about the king--
somebody wrote a novel
mentioning something about the
king they didn't like, they
threw them in jail.
And corruption is rampant in
all of these countries, so
that's kind of the setting.
Burma is different
in many respects.
Burma is kind of a unique
country, and I find it very
different from the rest
of Southeast Asia.
And if you look at Burma from
above, if you start in the
north, you're in the foothills
of the Himalayas, and it's
snow covered.
You start moving down south
and you hit jungle.
Then you hit sort of the arid
lands, and finally you're in
the delta, the rice growing
area, which is the lowlands.
This is a very, very
rich country.
It has enormous gas reserves,
which, in
fact, are being tapped.
Their offshore wells, they're
selling to all
the neighboring countries.
So they have gas, oil,
gems, rubies, jade,
lots of other minerals.
They have teak forests, and
they have agriculture.
Burma at one point was really
one of the richest countries
in Southeast Asia.
It was a big exporter of rice.
It had the best universities.
It was sort of a shining
example, and 50 years of
military rule have caused it
just to tumble to the bottom.
If there's a list of countries
and the poorest countries,
it's down there near
Egypt somewhere.
So I'd like to talk about
Burma sort of-- it's
very hard to do.
Frankly, this is very difficult
for me because of
the complexities of
this country.
It's a country of 130
plus languages.
There are nine major ethnic
groups, but really those break
up into subgroups.
The primary religion,
I think 85% of the
population are Buddhists.
I'm an electrical engineer.
I think we just got feedback.
But there are Christians,
there are Animists--
I may show you the Animists--
and there are Muslims.
And so this is a incredibly
diverse country, and I don't
know really what to do in
terms of presenting the
country to you, because there
are two complete visions.
There are the optimists, and
there are the skeptics, and I
don't know where the truth lies
in the realm of this.
And I don't know where the
country is going, frankly, and
anybody who tells you they
know is probably lying.
This is a country of 60 million
people, and the
question of course, is why--
when I did this film,
there was really a
high level of fear.
People were afraid to talk.
They were terrified, beatings,
torture, imprisonment.
I had one guy who is one of the
narrators in the film, and
he talks about what solitary
confinement, or was.
It was essentially, they put you
into a concrete tube, all
right, and the tube is so
small that you couldn't
stretch out, you couldn't
stand up, and
they closed the end.
That's solitary confinement, and
I think I could do about a
minute and a half, and so this
gives you an idea of what they
were capable of.
He mentions they put a bag over
his head with hungry mice
in it, and the mice were trying
to bite him, and he had
to bite the mice.
It's really Orwellian, which
is kind of interesting,
because George Orwell
spent time in Burma.
So there's a sort of the
before and after.
I've been there repeatedly,
and I was there for the
release of political prisoners,
and there was a
massive release.
But there still are political
prisoners in jail, and they're
not political prisoners,
because they are in for
criminal violations.
And it's very hard to separate
those criminal charges were
used essentially for
political reasons.
The country's changing, and the
question is, I think-- and
by way, feel free to interrupt
and ask questions, in fact, I
prefer that--
why did this country change?
You're aware that Aung San Suu
Kyi was in 15 years of house
arrest, and suddenly
she's released.
And why did this happen?
Well, I think it happened
because
of a number of reasons.
I think it's economic, I think
the military was interested in
doing business with the West,
and I think the West was dying
to do business with Burma.
Before, Burma's main trading
partner with China, also
Thailand and India, but Burma
has a 1,200 mile border with
China, and so Western
companies have been
essentially drooling now
trying to get in.
They've got their sights set on
60 million people who are
going to buy toothpaste, and
television sets, and computers.
I think also the Burmese
military was nervous about the
Chinese influence.
I think also that the generals
wanted to be free to travel,
and I think the generals wanted
to send their kids to
Cornell, so it's a combination
of all these factors that
caused, essentially,
the opening up.
And when I was there in the
beginning, there was
essentially one internet portal,
you know, and it could
be pulled at any time.
I couldn't get onto the Cornell
server to get my email.
Interestingly enough, Google
Mail worked, Gmail worked.
I don't know why.
It was really an exception.
And if you wanted to go to an
internet cafe, if you were
Burmese you had to register, you
had to give them your home
address, the name of
your school, the
name of your teacher.
But what's interesting is that,
and there were walls
everywhere, but the kids
understood about proxy
servers, and so they were
downloading country and
Western music.
In other words, the wall was
porous, information was coming
in, so this is not
North Korea.
This is, you know, somewhere
between the West, and
somewhere between North
Korea, potentially.
So there was internet, and
of course now it's
really opening up.
So there's these two views, by
the way, of where is the
country going.
Is it moving to democracy, or
is it essentially still
controlled by the military.
Well, there was a draft
constitution that was rammed
through at the time of Nargis,
this cyclone that hit, and
150,000 people were killed.
And the draft constitution
reserved 25% of the seats for
the military.
In addition to that, the USDA,
which is not the United States
Department of Agriculture, but
actually a political party,
many of those people are also
former military, so the
parliament is very heavily
weighted towards the military.
And Suu Kyi-- there was an
election now, a by-election--
she only won, in a landslide,
7% of the seats.
And the question really
is, can Aung San
Suu Kyi affect change?
The skeptics feel like the
military is still in control.
The optimists feel like
they're on the
cusp of major democracy.
Suu Kyi cannot become president,
because first of
all, if you have any relative,
if you or any relative have a
British passport, then you can't
run for the presidency.
So there are a big election
coming in 2015, but the real
question is can Aung San Suu
Kyi run for that president.
I assume you all know who
Aung San Suu Kyi is.
You do?
OK, she's one of the narrators
of our film, and I keep
running into her.
There was a Film Festival in
Yangon, and I ran into her,
and I always say, hi,
do you remember me?
And she says, yes, and then I
ran into her in the plaza.
They were giving an award
to her, and I
said, hi, how are you?
And I think she's at this point
now where she thinks I'm
stalking her, but you have
to admire the woman.
But there are people who really
don't like Suu Kyi, and
there are American scholars--
I showed this film at a meeting
of Burmese scholars,
and there were some
very upset people.
And they're upset because they
feel that Suu Kyi is sort of
stealing the show, that she's
getting all these awards.
She went to Bangkok before the
president Thein Sein went, and
he had to cancel his trip.
She's in the United States she's
at the UN, and on the
other hand, you have to really
admire this woman.
She gave up her family.
She was on house arrest, her
husband was dying, and she had
to make a choice.
Was she going to leave the
country and see her husband,
or once she left, she
could never go back.
Does she stay, does she go,
and of course she stayed.
She also gave up her children,
essentially, at a very tender
age, so this woman has made
enormous sacrifices.
You know, when I filmed her,
she had just been released.
Our film was just about
finished, and I was furious at
my editor, because he
was going so slow.
We were working two years on the
editing of this film, and
I've never worked out
long in a film.
And I was ready to strangle
David Kossack our editor, and
fortunately I didn't, because
she was released.
Then I flew back, and I had a
rare chance to sit with her
and interview her.
And I was determined not to
fawn over her, because
journalists in general tend
to fawn over her,
and so I didn't fawn.
But I went back later and I
looked at the rushes, and then
I started fawning.
This woman is very,
very smart.
Unlike most politicians--
if you interview George Bush
and you ask him A, he'll
answer with Z, his
prepared thing.
It doesn't matter if it answers
the question or not.
Suu Kyi is very, very smart,
and she's always listening.
And I think I surprised her
a bit, because I asked her
questions that she didn't
expect, because I
knew what we needed.
So I started off, for instance,
saying like, tell me
a little bit about Burma.
And she said, what?
Yeah, I said, tell me
about the country.
I said, I know you can't
do that in 10 minutes.
She says, I can't do
that in 10 hours.
Well, I said, tell me about the
diversity of the country,
and so actually I knew where we
were going, and fortunately
we were able to cut her in.
And it almost looks like we shot
her, and then we shot the
film around her, and of course
that's not the case, but I
think you have to
be the judge.
She integrates into the film.
Anyhow, she is very
impressive.
She's super smart, and she's
super articulate, and so I
find it hard to dump
on her, frankly.
But there are real issues in
Burma, and the issues are the
minority issues.
I don't know if you're
following the news.
There is a war going on with the
Kachin in the north west.
It's a fighting war.
The president has called for a
ceasefire, and said they will
not attack any more.
In the meanwhile, gunships are
going in, and attacking the
Kachin, and so it shows you the
military is running the
show, not the president.
There has been a major problem
with the Rohingya in the
Rakhine state, and the Rakhine
state is sort of over here.
The Kachin are up here,
and the Rakhine are
somewhere over there.
And in the Rakhine state there's
a minority called the
Rohingya, and they are Muslims,
and a Burmese woman
was raped by six Muslims.
And this started a massive
retaliation on both sides, and
the net result has been tens of
thousands of Rohingya displaced.
The Burmese, interestingly
enough, do not think of the
Rohingya as Burmese, or
Myanmar, residents.
They originally came from
Bangladesh, and some of them
have been there for
hundreds of years.
They are actually stateless,
and they cannot send their
children to school, they can't
own land, and here's where we
start to come into one
of the real problems.
A friend of mine who runs an
NGO, or did a big one in
Burma, said that Suu Kyi had a
choice, and she could have
either been sort of a moral
force, like Bishop Tutu, or a
politician, and she chose
to become a politician.
And as a result of that, you
know you get dirty when you're
a politician, and you're
making compromises.
Suu Kyi has asked about the
Rohingya, and she has really
not commented on them at all.
Here is a woman who has really
fought for human rights, but
has steered clear of this,
because it's a hot potato.
The Burmese, there's this
enormous hatred for the
Rohingya, and this is a case
where she wants to run for
office, and run for president
potentially, and if she makes
a statement about the Rohingya,
she's going to lose
a part of the electorate.
So she could have stayed above
the fray, and she decided to
get into it, and I think now
you're seeing sort of the
fissures that are occurring.
There have been a number
of minority wars.
The longest civil war on earth
was with the Karen, which are
a Christian group, essentially
in the eastern part of Burma,
and there is a ceasefire now.
But in 1949, General Aung San,
the father of Aung San Suu
Kyi, managed to pull most of
the minorities together at
this Panglong conference.
And they agreed that they would
work for independence
from the Brits, and later on,
you know, they would form a
federation.
The question really is now
whether Aung San Suu Kyi can
hold this country together
with its 130 languages.
It's amazing.
If you go up towards the Golden
Triangle in the north,
in the-- have to just check my
directions here-- in the
northeast, you can be dealing
with a tribal group, and go
over the hill and they speak a
totally different language.
They can't even speak
to one another.
How do you hold a country like
this together is probably the
big question.
When you speak about the
military, by the way, the
tendency is to think of it as
being monolithic, but the
truth of the matter is it is not
monolithic, that there are
some very progressive
generals.
So there are fissures within the
military also, so although
the military does control
things, it is
not a single body.
And one of the problems, of
course, with the opening up
is, essentially, resources.
The resources are controlled by
the military and by their
cronies, and one wonders
what's going to
happen in the future.
In other words, if you owned
all these resources, or you
had control, would you be
prepared to give it up, and I
think I know the
answer to that.
Yes, a good question.
I think you're talking about the
cyclone in August that hit
in 2008, right?
What effect did that have on
the country opening up?
I don't know, but I heard that
the-- this is hearsay--
that Thein Sein, who became
president, was down there at
the time, and people say for
him it was life changing,
seeing the situation where
150,000 people died.
At the time of the cyclone, the
military would not let in
relief supplies, which were
right there, essentially, in
Thailand, and the United States
wanted to offload
ships, and they wouldn't
let anybody in.
I don't know.
The military is not
transparent.
You just don't know what
they're thinking.
They do not share any
information whatsoever, so a
lot of what goes on is really
conjecture about where their
heads are at.
AUDIENCE: Do these state
boundaries correspond to the
ancient kingdoms?
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN:
Oh my god.
That's a hard question,
because there
were ancient kingdoms.
There is one kingdom that went
not just here, but it went all
the way to Ayutthaya
in Thailand.
I think that actually this
boundary is, and any historian
can correct me, it is not Iraq
that was put together,
essentially, by the British.
I think these are sort of
natural boundaries.
Any other questions, done?
Yes?
You'll have to walk.
Good.
AUDIENCE: So I watched
the film the other
day, and it was amazing.
I know that some people's faces
were blurred out because
of concerns for their safety,
but other people's weren't, so
I was just wondering.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: Well the
ones that weren't blurred out
are all now in jail or dead.
I'm joking.
Well, I blurred out the ones
that I thought were at risk.
For instance, people on the
street, if you just shoot them
it's fine, children are
basically innocent.
You know, when I've done films
before, I like to have stars,
as I call them.
In other words, I wanted
follow a family.
I couldn't follow a family,
because whoever I followed
would end up being arrested,
so this was a very
hard film to do.
In other words, how do
you do a film and not
have stars in it?
And what we decided is that
the country was the star,
basically, and I was very, very
worried about the people
who worked with me,
who helped me.
You saw in the film, I got in
trouble in a number of cases,
and I was worried about the
Burmese who were actually
working with me and
helping me.
I was teaching film there.
I was working with young film
directors, and when I would go
to film, I would make it a point
of always asking them to
disappear, and then
meet them later.
I was standing on the street--
I like to shoot crowds coming
at me, so I wanted people
ebbing around me, so I planted
myself on a busy street and
started shooting.
And then some woman passed me,
and tapped me three times on
the shoulder and disappeared,
and then I knew I was in
trouble, so I quickly wrapped
up and just took off.
Nowadays, you can go in
and you can film,
crews are going in.
But at that time--
I got in trouble for
filming vegetables.
I mean, it's bizarre.
I got in trouble for filming the
National Library, and as
you see in the film, this guy
keeps asking me to identify
myself, and we wanted to know
my name, and want to have my
name card, and what's your name,
what's your name, and he
kept going.
And I finally told him my name,
it's Shel Frequolm, and
I come from Stockholm, Sweden,
and I'm staying in the Park
View Summit, which was the other
of town, and I took off.
So I think they'll still looking
for Shel Frequolm.
I think that the big question is
like, what's the future of
the country now?
Where is it going to go?
Is consumerism going
to take off?
Are these people going to
lose their culture?
Is it going to become sort of
Bangkok, or is there really a
sense of culture and history
where they can
preserve all that.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Would you be
safe going back to
Myanmar to do more?
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: Would
I be safe going back?
I don't know.
I tried to show the film at the
American Center, and the
Americans did not
want to show it.
They were very nervous, and this
is after the opening up,
so I showed it at the British
Council, which is part of the
British embassy, and I showed
it one night, and the place
was packed with Burmese.
And I left the next morning at
6:00 AM, and I haven't been
back, so I can't answer
that question.
But I did meet Thein Sein's
personal representative in the
United States, and I gave him
a DVD, and I didn't even in
charge him the $29.95,
so I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Could you imagine
update the movie?
Would that make any sense?
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN:
Yeah, updating.
I've thought about it.
Are you willing to fund it?
AUDIENCE: Google will.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN:
Google will fund it.
I'm headed to North Korea.
That's my next film.
Seriously if I could
do that, yeah.
I did the second most isolated
country, and I think that
there's a need to have some
sort of perspective on the
situation in North Korea.
It's gotten a little hysterical,
as you're probably
aware, and so I feel like,
oh, that would be a
neat place to go.
There are real environmental
problems that exist in Burma.
First of all, the timber
is being cut.
These are the last of the
great teak forests, and
they're being cut down, and it's
not sustainable, and the
logging is illegal.
Inle Lake, you'll see this
beautiful lake in the movie,
and they grow tomatoes on it.
They have floating vegetable
gardens.
Essentially, the detritus
washes down from the
mountains, and it floats, and
they have tomato plants, and
you get to them with a boat,
and you can work on them.
The trouble, it's all beautiful,
but they're using
pesticides, and the lake is
seriously polluted, so that's
one environmental concern.
There's a big project
in the works.
There is a Thai-Italian company
that is prepared to
develop Dawei.
It is going to be a development
which is four
times the size of Manhattan.
It's petrochemical.
There are going to be roads
linking Dawei with Thailand.
The Chinese are building a
railroad, which will go from
Dawei up into Yenon.
Dawei is situated in such a
place where boats coming can
avoid the Straits of Malacca.
It's a fast run to China, and
so why are they doing this.
Why are the Thais involved
building Dawei?
Well, because of pollution
controls in Thailand.
They can get away with much
more than they could in
Thailand, and if you've been
in Thailand, then you
understand.
Been in Bangkok and know what
the pollution is like there,
you can see that this is just
a disaster in the making.
The Chinese are building
dams on--
there was a big project, the
Myitsone dam, which was going
to be built by the Chinese, and
it has been put on hold.
Or I don't know if it's been
canceled or not, but there are
other dams going in.
There's been really popular
uprising against these dams.
What's the future
of the country?
Well, the country really needs
experts, and not just Western
experts, but it needs Burmese
who know what's going on, and
can speak the language.
And there are huge Burmese
communities here
in the United States.
The people there are educated.
They know banking, they know
medicine, but the question is,
will they come back?
The military has a get out of
jail for free card, but the
dissidents don't.
And the dissidents who've
lived here in the United
States, and the Burmese who
have fled here for asylum,
they have families, they have
children, they have houses and
cars, the kids go to school.
Are they prepared to give up
that and return, so that's a
big question mark.
The whole country really,
as I see it, is a
big question mark.
I'd like to show you some
outtakes which didn't make it
into the film.
If you decide to go during the
rainy season, this is what it
looks like.
When it rains in Burma
it pours, literally.
This is just an ordinary
rainfall, and the rainy season
runs from essentially--
I think it starts in June
and runs up to the fall.
I think you get the idea.
Do you want to go
to orphanages?
All right, so where are
we going, tell me.
You're my driver today, huh?
I have a high class driver.
DRIVER: Yeah.
We are heading to the outskirts
of Rangoon, south of
Rangoon, the city called
[? Kyauktan. ?]
[? Kyauktan ?] is a southern
district of the Rangoon.
It has also been ravished by
the storms, cyclone Nargis,
that this area.
But our idea is to go
to the orphanage.
This orphanage is run by a
Buddhist monk, and they told
me that they have 300
orphans there.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN:
This is really uncut
footage, in a sense.
It's not the polished.
DRIVER: Some are from the
southern Shan state, some are
from the Kachin state,
some are Kayin state.
They have been orphaned by
various reason, because their
mothers have died, or they have
been starved, of there's
nobody to care for them.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: Mostly we
have battles in
the border line area.
That's one of the reasons that
we come to an orphanage.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: Are the
mothers killed too, or just
the fathers?
TRANSLATOR:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: Some mothers left,
or the father passed away, or
both are gone.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: [INAUDIBLE]
and then when we saw any orphan,
just pick it up and
bring it back.
DRIVER: The Kayah, some of the
land owners who get this land,
[INAUDIBLE]
students.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN:
In other words, they
raise their own food.
DRIVER: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's right.
Right, right, right.
Sometimes, some of the foods
have been donated by the local
community there, but
it is not enough.
For that amount of children, you
need some donations from
local community, as well as
from foreign countries.
But now, some of the wiser
orphans and children are
working in the fields
to get their food.
So they have to go into the
plantations, like rice
plantations and bean
plantations.
They are working in the field
now, and some are working,
repairing of the monastery, like
painting the walls, and
repair some furniture
like that.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: In the morning time
you clean, have to go to
the [INAUDIBLE].
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: 6 o'clock,
wake up.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: 5, 6 o'clock
wake up.
DRIVER: I liaise between donors
and the Buddhist monks,
and whenever--
especially from Americans.
South Americans get in contact
with the nursery.
They ask me what sort of
items are most needed.
Buddhist monk has hired the plot
of land to plow for the
food, so they have
to hire them.
So the first thing is that
you need money to
buy all of the land.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN:
How old is she?
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: 12.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN:
12, and how long has
she been living here?
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN:
Three years.
How old he?
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: 12.
TRANSLATOR: 13.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: Nine years old.
TRANSLATOR: 10 years, OK.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: Eight years old.
TRANSLATOR: I said where's
your mother and father?
In the village.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: I
see, so they were too
poor to keep her?
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN:
Is he studying to
be a monk, or what?
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: I want to learn.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: Why?
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
TRANSLATOR: I want
to be educated.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: So one
of the themes that you keep
running into, of course, is
education, and the education
system was wrecked.
Originally, Burma had
the top universities
in Southeast Asia.
Everybody came to
Burma to study.
I went to dinner with somebody,
and we were talking,
and I kept on having to
say what, what, what.
You know, I just couldn't
understand what they were
saying, and finally I said, by
the way, what do you do for a
living, and he said,
I teach English.
And as you see in the movie,
the educational system is
rote, basically, and the people
teaching in the schools
English don't speak English.
Probably the most pressing thing
for Burma right now is
essentially rebuilding the
educational system.
I think it's almost more
important than food at this
point, so--
pardon?
AUDIENCE: I have
a [INAUDIBLE].
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN:
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: The education system
was actually stopped at one
point in the '80s, where all
the schools were stopped.
I have cousins and stuff that
were on their last year
graduating with master's in
computer science and stuff,
and they literally had to drop
out of school, had nowhere to
go, and joined shipping
companies, climbing 100 foot
poles to make ends meet.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: My
understanding is that from
what my Burmese friends
at the university,
bribery gets you there.
And also at the high school, the
teachers supposedly teach,
but then you have to hire
them after school.
AUDIENCE: I was just
there in January.
I was there for new year, and
Yangon felt like it was--
I mean, the only infrastructure
there was built
by the British, otherwise there
wasn't infrastructure.
So, I mean, to what extent they
invested, that's what's
in the country.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: Yeah, but
I think it's very limited
what they did.
I mean, there's some buildings
in Yangon that are built by
the British, but generally if
you travel around the country,
the British didn't
do that much.
AUDIENCE: And then I remember
taking the highway down from--
what is it--
Mandalay, right from Yangon.
What is the story behind
the highway, exactly?
I heard numerous facts, but that
it was financed by the
US, and no-one's ever on it, so
it's like kind of this huge
piece of infrastructure and but
the Burmese kind of don't
use it or can't use it
because of the tolls.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: I can't
answer that question, but I
know there's a superhighway
that goes from Yangon, or
Rangoon, to Naypyidaw, which
is the new capital.
By the way, the Burmese
government took all civil
servants and moved them to
Naypyidaw, which is sort of
the Brasilia of Myanmar.
And people think that's bizarre,
but if you look at
the history of the kings, what
they did is when a new king
came, they left the old city
and built a new city.
And I think the military must
be thinking of themselves as
sort of the new kings, and the
military, if you talk to them,
they feel like they're doing
the right thing.
They're helping the country.
There are holding it together.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: What do you think is
responsible for the density of
linguistic diversity in Burma?
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: Oh wow.
Well, I'm probably not the guy
to answer it, but I mean,
there were the original
indigenous
populations that were--
whoops, the map is gone.
Anyhow, there was also,
essentially, from Tibet
populations came down.
There was all this mixing.
I don't really know.
I'm not a linguist.
Yeah, anyhow, I'm afraid to
answer that question.
I'm always amazed that
people speak
different languages, right.
And children growing up invent
their own words, right,
because we're hardwired
for language somehow.
BRIAN KINDLER: You've got a
pretty interesting audience
here at Google and on YouTube
who are going to be watching
this, so where do you think we
could make the biggest impact?
And I'm not talking like
philanthropy or volunteering,
I'm talking in terms of how we
make, and create, and develop
our products?
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: The
Burmese are enormously hungry
for the outside world.
When I was first there, I was
one of the few Americans in
the country, and--
oh, I want to show
you something.
Do we have a minute?
Where are you from?
Here, let me show
you something.
Apropos this.
Where are you from, is that--
BRIAN KINDLER: Where
am I from?
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: No,
there's one called, well--
BRIAN KINDLER: Rural
life tribes.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: Oh,
we don't have it.
BRIAN KINDLER: We
don't have it.
DR. ROBERT LIEBERMAN: One of the
questions that people kept
asking me, where are you from,
and I would say, well, where
do you think I'm from?
And they would say, Germany,
no, Switzerland, no, Italy,
no, and it would go on and on,
and finally I'd say America,
and it was like, oh,
from America.
And there just were very, very
few Americans in Burma.
Of course this has completely
changed, right.
By the way, there are
some problems.
Tourists are pouring in faster,
essentially, than the
country can absorb them.
And also, aid money is coming in
almost too fast to be used,
and all the Western companies
are looking at Burma and
preparing investments, and so
there's this enormous--
it's like a cauldron,
essentially it's all just
bubbling, and the future
is the big mystery.
And I think that information
is empowerment, as I
mentioned, and perhaps Google
can somehow penetrate Burma.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]